So you don't need to memorize hundreds or thousands
of trade setups to be a good trader.
You only need to get good at recognizing a few.
In my 25 years of trading and now 15 years of teaching,
including creating 50 plus millionaire students from scratch,
here are the five basic setups
that have made my students and I the most money.
And stay tuned for number five
because this is my favorite setup, especially for beginners.
Setup number one, the multi-day breakout at any time.
So what do I mean by a multi-day breakout?
Here's an example, an STEM was spiking right here
and you can see this, this was in mid July,
we were in Las Vegas.
And I love looking at past highs
and seeing where that key breakout level is.
And you can see here, clear as day on July 18th,
there was a breakout above this former high here in mid June.
And pretty big green candle right at the highs.
And now it's easy to say, yeah, in hindsight,
it spiked up and it was a nice breakout.
But I actually did it in real time.
And a lot of my inner circle students were surprised.
I was sitting right next to Stradi actually.
He's my newest millionaire student
as of the time I'm filming this.
And he didn't even understand.
He was like, why are you buying this?
And I'm like, this is an unknown AI play
and it is breaking out today, okay?
Sometimes that's all it takes.
I need you to understand that we're looking at charts,
technical analysis matters.
And if you look at these charts and focus on them,
you will see stocks that have hit a very specific price,
two, three, four, five days ago,
two, three, four, five weeks ago.
You're looking for that very specific price
and you're looking for a breakout over that price.
Why does it matter?
Because there are so many different traders
who have technical screens
and they look for specific breakouts over key levels.
And you want as many traders
looking at one key level as possible.
Why?
Because longs like to buy those breakouts.
It shows that the stock might be in for a bigger run-up.
And you also have short sellers.
Short sellers bet against stocks.
If the stock that they're betting against hits a new high,
they stop out, okay?
That's what responsible short sellers do.
So when you add that key multi-day
or ideally multi-week breakout point,
all the longs are focused on that breakout.
So you get a rush of new buyers
and the shorts are focused on that breakout level
and they wanna cover their shares.
When a short seller covers their shares,
they're buying back to cover.
So you have two groups of buyers
at this key specific breakout point.
When you have those two groups,
usually you get a rush and you get a quick breakout,
especially if it's a lower price volatile play
in a hot sector like AI or crypto right now.
And you get that multi-day multi-week breakout.
The stock cannot just break out one or 2%,
but oftentimes that breakout is 10, 20, 30%
within a few minutes or a few hours.
You do have to be careful though,
if you're going for that breakout
and for whatever reason it breaks out a little bit
and then it comes smashing back down.
That happens.
There are fake out breakouts.
But in an ideal world,
you buy the multi-day multi-week breakout.
All you have to do is draw a simple line on your chart,
look at the previous high,
and if it breaks it convincingly,
the stock usually rises quite a bit,
especially if there's the right news catalyst,
if it's in a hot sector,
if we're in a bull market like we are right now in 2025.
I literally interviewed David Hamlin just a few weeks ago.
He just crossed $10 million in profits.
He made a million dollars on his crypto breakout.
Bitcoin broke out to new highs.
Aaron said, have there been false breakouts
that you've seen recently where you wanted to size in,
but something didn't work?
Stuff has honestly been working pretty well
for the most part just in this current market
because everything's really hot.
It was a trick question.
I know everything's working.
It's great.
Welcome to the bull market, buy those breakouts.
So setup number two are these morning spikers
and lately this is including pre-market starting at 4 a.m.
I know it's not fun to get up at 4 a.m. Eastern.
Congratulations if you're one of my European students,
you live in the right time zone.
But whether it's 4 a.m., whether it's 7 a.m.,
whether it's 9.30 a.m.,
these three key times are when stocks can really spike.
4 a.m. Eastern is when a lot of brokers
like Interactive Brokers open.
7 a.m. Eastern is when retail brokers
like E-Trade or TD Ameritrade open.
9.30 a.m. Eastern is when every broker opens
and that's normal market hours.
But these key levels are when, guess what?
The stock market opens and people can buy stocks.
So I'm looking for stocks with news.
I'm looking for stocks with volume.
I'm trying to buy stocks that are already up 5%, 10%, 20%,
even 50% because in this market,
a stock that's already up gets all these traders interested.
There's all these different chat rooms right now in 2025.
It's a crazy bull market.
So traders are looking for anything that is moving
because a stock that's up 10, 20, 30% can go up 50, 100, 200
with the right news catalyst.
I wouldn't buy a stock without a news catalyst.
There are a lot of morning spikers that just spike
because different chat rooms are buying them.
When the chat room buys them, they go up.
When the chat room sells them, they go down very quickly.
You don't really know.
If there's a news catalyst, if there's enough volume,
if the stock is already spiking a little bit,
and ideally if enough short sellers are lured
into shorting it, you are supposed to buy this stock.
I know it's scary to just buy any stock spiking,
but ideally I like buying a stock
on a 10 or 20% dip off the morning highs.
And then if it breaks through the highs,
it can spike very fast as the shorts cover
as more other traders buy the breakout.
If you're liking this video, make sure you go back
and watch this video about how I consistently find
the best stocks to day trade and subscribe to this channel
so you don't miss any of my upcoming videos
filled with endless trading knowledge and tips
that I've learned the hard way over 25 years.
Setup number three that I love are these afternoon
and after hours breakouts.
This is when there's been a lot of price action
that's happened all day that you can now bounce ideas off of.
And ideally there was a high set at 7 a.m.
or 9 a.m. or 12 p.m.
But there's a distinct high of the day set already
and you're looking for a breakout over that key level
in the afternoon or after hours.
And I actually like afternoon and after hour setups,
especially for beginners because they're not as fast
as morning spikers or pre-market spikers.
In the afternoon, there's a lot of data
from that day already.
So you might not get the same excessive breakouts
or the same excessive runs that you would get
early in the morning, but it's safer.
And oftentimes it's a lot easier for newbies
who are not used to the speed and the volatility
that comes with morning spikers or pre-market spikers.
This is a good example of an afternoon runner.
So this is the daily chart,
but let me just show you the last 10 days.
This doesn't just run all day long.
This actually runs at different times.
So let me show you this one minute chart.
And this one actually tends to do pretty poorly
in the morning, probably just because it's up
for so many days, so many weeks,
and shorts are trying to pound them into the ground.
So if it starts to fade in the morning,
hopefully shorts are trying to push it down
so that it panics by midday and in the afternoon.
But every time it makes a new high,
the shorts give up and they get squeezed
and it oftentimes becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy.
When a few shorts get squeezed, they're scared of new highs,
they create the new highs that they're so scared of.
So as you can see here, this was roughly a week ago
and the stock was in the 14s coming down.
And then it kind of bounces a little bit,
but it doesn't make new highs.
Here you have a little uptrend and right around 1.40 PM
and really specifically 2.20 PM here,
you have a nice run up to new highs.
Again, it starts the next day here,
kind of unconvincing breakout.
I mean, it's still higher than here in the 14s,
it's up to the 15s and 16s, but not much.
Again, by the afternoon, when the trend is clear
for the day, that's when it can run.
At the same time too, it's less risky because guess what?
If it fails, if the stock does not break out,
if the stock for whatever reason fails
to really explode up in the afternoon or after hours,
you just cut it and the market is a lot less unforgiving
than in the morning.
So if you like slower moving trades,
if you like safer trades, I would focus on the afternoon.
Setup number four, I love dip buying morning panics,
especially on multi-day runners.
You have to think about some of these stocks
that have been spiking for two, three, four, five,
six days in a row.
Sometimes people are riding them up.
Congratulations to those people with patience.
I'm not one of them.
Because I'm not one of them, I'm always looking for a deal.
No different than like shoppers are looking
at Black Friday deals.
So too, I'm looking for deals in the stock market.
When a stock has been running for several days,
I'm looking for an opportunity to get in on a dip.
And sometimes this happens very quickly,
especially near the market open,
where longs who have been using stop losses
as they ride a stock higher and higher, they get taken out.
This was a few years ago, ZPAS.
This was a multi-day runner
over the past few days ahead of time.
And you can see here, right near the open,
it tanks from 260 down to the 170s,
and then bounces very quick.
So if you're prepared for these big panics,
that would be great to dip buy.
For example, if a stock, let's say,
has gone from one to six over five days,
and the stock drops in the morning for whatever reason,
due to the market, due to some negative news,
due to just some profit taking,
if it drops from six to five, and $5 is a round number,
so a lot of newbies use stop losses right at round numbers
to try to protect themselves,
if all those stop losses at $5 a share get taken out,
it creates a tsunami of automated sell orders.
And a stock might drop from $5 a share down to like 450,
or even $4 a share, within a few seconds or a few minutes.
And that opens the door to a nice, solid opportunity
where the stock, for literally no reason or a small reason,
might drop 20, 30, 40% within a few seconds
or a few minutes, and if you're prepared,
you can then utilize your small account to your advantage,
and then you can flip it for a quick 5, 10, 20% bounce
sometimes.
It's not as easy as the breakout buys,
and you do have to worry about trying
to catch a falling knife.
There's a saying, if you try to catch a falling knife,
you end up with bloody hands.
So sometimes if the stock drops,
and it's not just due to stop losses,
but it's due to actually some big bad news
that you don't know about, the stock can keep dropping.
So it is a little risky to just dip by a panic
without knowing why.
But if you know that there's no specific big bad reason
that the stock is dropping,
and it probably is just stop losses,
you can scalp that quick.
I've done it throughout my career many times,
especially in the past.
In 2025, dip buys haven't worked as great
because a lot of the biggest runners
are just short squeezes, and once the shorts cover,
there's really not that many buyers left.
But at the same time, if there's the right setup,
and specifically, you're watching these multi-day setups,
then you have more time.
Because if you're watching a stock spike
two, three, four, five, six, seven days in a row,
you should be watching it every morning
for a potential panic dip buy opportunity.
So knowing the best times to buy and sell,
it's amazing knowing these key setups,
but I really want you to watch this other video that I did
on when to take profits, when to cut losses,
because that really applies to these setups.
Number five, my favorite setup for beginners.
Save the best for last.
It's the first green day pattern.
Why is it the best?
Because it's the slowest moving.
As a newbie, I know that it's very confusing.
A lot of these plays move very fast.
This is so simple.
It's literally just buying a stock into the close,
whether it's 4 p.m., normal market hours,
or 8 p.m., after hours hours.
But either way, you're buying the stock
on a first green day.
What does that mean?
The candle, if you look in the daily chart, is green,
but also you wanna buy a stock that's up 10, 20, 30, 40%
already.
You want the stock in play.
Ideally, you want there to be a catalyst.
I really love the first green day.
This is a beautiful breakout, multi-day, multi-week breakout
first green candle.
Look for these big candles
because that's when they can keep going.
LAC, let's go to the daily chart.
You can see here the big gap up.
This was a first green day.
And the first green day leads to a second green day.
So don't be afraid to buy high.
And the first green day pattern
is all about buying this momentum
where there's a little bit of price discovery,
where the company, for whatever reason,
based on the news, based on the chart,
ideally based on the news and the chart,
is getting discovered.
And when it's the first day,
because most people are not focused on small caps
and micro caps, there's a timing inefficiency,
especially over the weekend.
My single best and most winning strategy of all
is buying a stock on a first green day on a Friday
and then selling it on a Monday
as people like to research it over the weekend.
But whether people are seeing the stock on the scans
or researching it over the weekend or just overnight,
no matter what, they're buying it on day two
because it just popped up on their radar.
This is why I love the inefficiency
that exists in the small cap and micro cap market
because there's very little following
and as far as I know, most people are not following
these stocks day to day, let alone minute to minute
like I like to do.
So there's a huge opportunity to buy these stocks
on day one, then other traders find it
on day two, day three, day four.
Guess what?
A lot of these stocks that start spiking 50, 100, 200, 500%,
they don't do it all in one day.
It takes several days.
So if you're there after the news is already out,
you don't have to guess the news ahead of time
and after the stock has already closed strongly
on a first green day, you can then ride the momentum
into day two, day three, day four.
Jack Kellogg, my top student of all time now
over $22 million, this is his favorite pattern
because he's taking bigger positions now
with his millions of dollars and he's swing trading
and he's profiting by holding a stock that gets discovered
whether it's a small cap stock or a micro cap stock,
AI or crypto, either way, there's some kind of news catalyst
and some kind of technical action
that gets in on everyone's radars
and then the momentum carries over for several days.
Obviously anything can happen overnight
so it doesn't work 100% of the time,
but if you're trying to take the meat of the move
and you're buying the momentum,
look for that first green day on a stock closing strongly
with a news catalyst and sell it day two, day three,
day four, your choice.
I hope this has helped you,
but if you have any questions, comment below,
I'll answer you and I'll see you in the next video.